so we've seen that partial orders are a
set of axioms that capture
the positive path relation
or the
uh arbitrary path relation in directed
acyclic graphs or dags but there's still
another way to understand these axioms
that gives a kind of representation
theorem for the kinds of for a kind of
mathematical objects that are partial
orders and that every partial order
looks like
so let's look at that example i'm
interested in the proper subset relation
a is a proper subset of b
which you remember means that b has
everything in it that a has and
something extra so in particular since b
has something extra b is not a subset of
a certainly not a proper subset of a
so let's look at an example of that here
are seven sets
and the arrows indicate the proper
subset relation or more precisely the
positive path relation
in this
graph represents the proper subset
relation where arrows are understood
where edges are understood to be
pointing upwards so i've left out the uh
the arrow heads this is also known as a
hassa diagram
where the height is an indication of
what you of which way the arrows go so
if arrows are pointing up this is
telling me that for example this set of
two elements one and five because
there's a path up to the top set the top
set has everything that this lower set
has namely the top set has one and five
and it's got extra stuff
one the set consisting of just one is a
proper subset of one and five because
the set has one in it but it has an
extra thing five and also there's a path
from one up to one two five ten because
1 2 5 10 has a 1 in it and extra stuff
so that's what the picture is
illustrating the proper subset relation
on this particular collection of seven
sets
now let's look at a very similar example
of the proper divides relation on some
numbers so proper divides means a
properly divides b if a divides b and
it's not equal to b and i'm interested
in the proper divides relation on this
set of seven numbers 1 2 3 5 10 15 and
30. and
now there's a path from 5 to 30 because
5 is a divisor of 30 and it's not equal
to 30 it's a proper divisor of 30. and
of course the point of this picture is
to show that the proper divides relation
on these seven numbers has exactly the
same shape as the proper subset relation
on those
seven sets
so there's the seven sets and their
proper subset relation shown by the
picture followed by the proper divides
relation on this set of seven numbers
and
the precise notion or sense in which
these things have the same shape
obviously they can be drawn and one
superimposed on the other but abstractly
what we care about with partial orders
and digraphs in general is
when
things are isomorphic
is the technical name for the same shape
and isomorphic means that all we care
about are the connections
uh between
corresponding vertices two graphs where
the vertices correspond in a way that
where there's a connection from between
two vertices there's also a connection
between the corresponding vertices or
isomorphic and the precise definition of
isomorphic is that isomorphic when
there's an edge preserving matching
between their vertices matching means
bijection and the formal definition is
g1 is isomorphic to g2 if and only if
there's a bijection from v1 the vertices
of g1 to v2 the vertices of g2 with the
property that if there's an edge between
two vertices u and v
in the first graph then there's an edge
between the corresponding two vertices f
of u and f of v in the second graph and
that's an if and only if relation
there's an edge between f of u and f of
v if and only if there's an edge between
u and v in the original graph that's the
official definition of isomorphism for
digraphs
and the theorem that we illustrated with
that example of proper divides and
a proper subset is that in fact
every strict partial order
is isomorphic to some collection of
subsets
partially ordered by less than so this
is a kind of a representation theorem if
you want to know
what kinds of things are
partial orders the answer is that a
strict partial order is something that
looks like a bunch of sets under
containment it's isomorphic to a bunch
of sets under containment
and the proof actually of this is is
quite straightforward what i'm going to
do to to find an isomorphism is you give
me your arbitrary
partial strict partial order r
and i'm going to map an element a in the
domain of r to the set of all of the
elements that are quote below it that is
all of the elements that are related to
r so a is going to map to the set of b's
such that b r a or b is equal to a and
that is added for a technical condition
remember r is strict so a is not related
to a under r but i want it to be in the
set that that a maps to so i'm throwing
that in another way to say this is that
the mapping f of a is equal to r inverse
of a union a and let's just illustrate
that
by the example of the how do you turn
the divides relation into the subset
relation well the smallest element in
the divides proper divides example was
this the number one and i'm going to map
it to the set consisting of one which is
all of the elements that properly divide
one along with one and then i'm going to
map the number three to all of the
elements that properly divide three
along with three and that is one and
three five maps to one and five two maps
to one and two
and at the next level i'm going to map
15 to all of the numbers that properly
divide 15 along with 15 so
1 3
5 and 15 are what the
number 15 maps to that's a set and
likewise 10 maps to 1 2 5 15 and 30 maps
to all of the numbers that are below it
including itself and this is the general
illustration of the way that you take an
arbitrary strict partial order and map
elements into sets which are basically
their inverse images under the relation
and the sets have exactly the same
structure under proper containment
as
the relation so this is again a
representation theorem that tells us
that if we want to understand partial
orders they are doing nothing more than
talking about relations with the same
structure as the proper
subset relation on some collection of
sets